[Music]
welcome dear friends to our question and
answer program here at Secrets unsealed
in Su TV I'd like to know this is a
program where you send us your questions
we do the research and then we do
everything possible to answer the
question on the air let me give you the
address where you can send us your
questions you'll see it on the screen
it's
TV Su tv.org once again TVM
tv.org we Delight in receiving your
questions please let us know where you
are sending your question from if at all
possible
I have with me Pastor David Salazar one
of our staff here at secret
seld glad to have you with us today
thank you Pastor a blessing to be with
you here and um I just want to remind
you to please support us through your
prayers and through your financial
contributions which helps us carry
present truth to the world uh before we
begin to answer the questions we want to
ask the Lord to be with us amen so I'm
going to ask Pastor to please have a
word of prayer let's pray Heavenly
Father we come before you at this hour
to uh ask of you the gift of the Holy
Spirit to be able to receive not only
the discernment the knowledge and
understanding but also the right words
the right speech to speak the things
that are true and that will honor your
name that will bring the knowledge of
the Bible to those who are watching that
they may have answers from your word
that will satisfi their desire to know
your will for their lives even better we
thank you for being with us and we once
again thank you for giving your son who
died on the cross for us we pray in His
holy name amen
amen well folks once in a while we get
questions on this program that are
impossible to answer in one and
sometimes even two programs
and the next question that we have
received is one of those questions that
is so complex the study because you have
to study the grammar you have to study
the syntax you have to study the
context and uh really uh it's a question
that cannot be fully answered in this
program so um before I share some
resource information that you can use to
fully understand this passage I'm going
to ask Pastor Salasar to uh read the
question and uh and the passage that is
in view here absolutely uh the question
is actually the second question that was
given by Robert G and um the question
comes from the book of Hebrews chap
12: 22 and 23 and I'm going to read the
question the verses and I'll then read
the question it says there in Hebrews 12
vers vers 22 and
23 but you have come to Mount Zion and
to the city of the Living God the
heavenly Jerusalem to an innumerable
company of angels to the general
assembly and Church of the firstborn who
are registered in heaven to God the
judge of all to the spirits of just men
made
perfect that's the two uh verses that he
asked and the question he has in regards
to this is the
following it looks like people have
their own Spirit or spirits that are
separated from God's spirit or the bread
of life how would you explain this
passage okay the first thing that I want
to do is uh share some information about
resources that we have available here at
Secrets unsealed this is a very
important question mhm because it is
used by uh people from other
denominations
to try and say that they the spirits of
The Departed are in heaven right but a
careful study of the passage indicates
that that is not the meaning of the
passage um uh for October through
December of 2022 the general conference
Sabbath school department asked me to
write the lessons for inverse which is
the youth Sabbath School quarterly MH
and um the Sabbath School quarter I
don't know if it's still available it's
uh
inverse uh it was actually prepared
uh for that quarter October through
December of the Year
2022 um it's also available in Spanish
uh Spanish one is larger than the
English one but uh the Sabbath school
lesson only gives a synthesis of a
greater longer study that I did uh
before this uh I did a 24-part series on
the state of the Dead MH and um I have
study notes on those misinterpreted
texts on the state of the Dead uh you
know this deals with many of those very
very difficult passages if I could just
read uh some of the titles of the
chapters um you have absent from the
body and present with the Lord a thief
and a
witch the thief on the cross and The
Witch of Endor right uh Rachel's
departing Spirit you know when her
spirit was departing uh when she was
dying she had Benjamin uh Paul's Dilemma
to stay or to depart the souls that are
crying out under the altar the spirit of
spirits of just men made perfect
preaching to the spirits in
prison um the Dead who stand before God
uh the rich man in Lazarus all of those
difficult texts that are misused by the
Christian world I deal with in this
particular uh study notes and so I would
encourage uh those who are watching the
program to uh um go to our website
download our app uh I think these study
notes are on our app uh which is
downloadable for free and uh just go
there and read the study notes there's
Pages answering this particular question
so it's very very uh difficult to do in
just one program now uh let me just read
the
passage uh with a verb
tenses that are in Greek okay because
many of the translations don't capture
the tense of the verb correct so I'm
going to read first of all this is from
the new King James version then I'm
going to read it from The New
International
Version uh it says but you that is the
Hebrews that were alive that he was
writing to that Paul was writing to you
have come it's perfect active tense mhm
in other words you have come it happened
in the past and it still endures to the
present MH you have come to Mount Zion
and to the city of the Living God the
heavenly Jerusalem to an innumerable
company of angels through the general
assembly and Church of the
firstborn and the translation of the new
King James says and the Church of the
firstborn who are registered in heaven
mhm that's not the verbal tense in Greek
in Greek it is who have been registered
in heaven in other words previously to
this the Hebrews had been written in
heaven and they were still written in
heaven now it's very clear that those
Hebrews who were alive in the days of
Paul were not literally in the Heavenly
Jerusalem they couldn't be there they're
there because they are citizens there in
other words their name is written there
in that sense they're there it continues
saying here
um let's go back then but you have come
to Mount Zion into the city of the
Living God the heavenly Jerusalem to an
innumerable company of angels to the
general assembly and Church of the
firstborn who have been written in
heaven to God the judge of all and then
comes the controversial uh statement to
the spirits of just men made perfect
yeah made perfect but really it is who
have been made perfect once again it's a
perfect tense and so it's very
distressing sometimes when when in the
same passage some verbs are translated
in the perfect tense and then others are
not translated in the perfect tense um
and a perfect tense of course is that uh
something that happened in the past that
endures in the present and then it
continues saying here and to Jesus the
mediator of the New Covenant and to the
blood of sprinkling that speaks better
than that that of Abel unfortunately the
expression that of is not in the
Greek so really what it says to the
blood of sprinkling that speaks better
things than able mm okay correct now
let's read in the NIV which is more
precise as far as the tenses are
concerned but you the living Hebrews
have
come to Mount Zion to the Heavenly
Jerusalem the city of the Living God
you the Hebrews that are alive at Paul's
time have come to thousands upon
thousands of Angels in joyful assembly
to the Church of the firstborn whose
names are here once again the NIV does
not reflect the tense it's perfect
passive tense whose names have been
written in heaven is what it says in
Greek MH and then it goes on you have
come to God the judge of all men to the
spirits of righteous men made
perfect that have been made perfect is a
better translation to Jesus the meteor
of the New Covenant and to the sprinkled
blood that speaks be a better word than
the blood of Abel that uh expression
then the blood is not in the text
correct okay now with that in mind and
I'm not going to take a whole lot of
time on this because uh you know if I
went into everything it would take this
program and the next there are three
things that we need to resolve when we
read this passage mhm number one who are
the just men correct that are made
perfect what are the spirits of the just
men who are made perfect and number
three what does it mean that they're
made perfect correct the spirits of just
men made
perfect well I'm going to give a short
answer the just Men by the way the word
men is added to the
text so really it says the just to the
righteous the righteous or to the just
correct we need to be careful about
adding uh adding words that are not
there or taking a words that are taking
away words that are there so really what
it says you have come to the just made
perfect now who are the just made
perfect the just made perfect are the
heroes of chapter 11 correct those that
have died di okay th those are the are
the just and why doesn't why shouldn't
we translate just men because on that
list there are women
too you look on in Hebrews 11 there are
women mentioned on that list so to the
just made perfect whether they're men or
women so now we know that the just are
the heroes of Hebrews 11 that by the
time of Paul have passed away mhm now
what are the spirits of just men
well we usually understand the
spirit as the
breath but the spirit is more than the
breath it has a broader definition MH
yes it's the breath but it is the it is
the character that we develop with the
breath that God gives us absolutely I
want to read a statement from Ellen
White where she explains what the spirit
is MH this is found in the book Marin
page
301 she said she wrote our personal
identity is preserved in the
resurrection so she's talking about dead
people right mhm our personal identity
is preserved in the resurrection though
not the same particles of matter or
material substance as went into the
grave the wondrous words of works of God
are a mystery to man now here comes the
key portion the
spirit comma yeah the character of man
man comma
mhm returns to God there to be preserved
mhm so what is the spirit in a broader
definition it is the character that is
written in
heaven that's right God has another me
in heaven in written form right in other
words and whether I'm saved or not saved
based on the record mhm and so when it
speaks about the spirits or the spirit
of the righteous of Hebrews 11 it's
speaking about their names being written
in heaven their character being
registered in heaven that's why it says
registered Right In this passage so then
the question is in what sense were these
Spirits or this record made
perfect the answer is very simple you
have to understand how the word perfect
applies to Christ
do you know that in the book of Hebrews
it uses the word perfect to describe
something that happened with Jesus mhm
yes it's not talking about moral
perfection no the word perfect as it
refers to Jesus is talking about um
Jesus becoming qualified to save
us the qualification that Jesus needed
in order to save us what did he need to
do he need to live a perfect life and he
had to die for sin right would make him
make him perfect or qualify him to save
us absolutely notice for example Hebrews
10 2:1 for it was fitting for him that
is for Jesus for whom for for whom are
all things and by whom are all things in
bringing many sons to glory to make the
captain of their salvation perfect
through sufferings that's right Jesus
was made perfect through what suffering
through his sufferings notice Hebrews 5
verses 7
to9 who in the days of his flesh when he
had offered up prayers and supplications
with vem cries this is Gethsemane with
the vem cries and tears to him who was
able to save him from death and was
heard because of his Godly fear though
he was a son yet he learned obedience by
the things which he suffered once again
his sufferings right and having been
perfected incredible not morally he
never sinned perfected means he had to
go through these sufferings to be
qualified to save us and says having
been made perfect he became the author
of Eternal salvation to all who obey
himh now the question is could the
records of the saved in the Old
Testament be made
perfect by the blood of bulls and goats
no he could not they their record could
not be perfected no with the the Old
Testament system it had to be with
Christ and his sacrifice but when Jesus
paid for their sins right could their
record be made perfect could they
legally be saved absolutely absolutely
and that is why Pastor just to just you
know insert this thought in Hebrews
11:40 it ends with this expression God
having provided something better for us
that they speaking of those that that
describe chapter 11 that they should not
be made perfect there you go there you
go so that's the kind of the the key and
it helps us understand how serious it is
to add the blood of abble correct really
what it's saying is that the blood of
Christ speaks better things than the
blood that Abel shed that's right not
not the not the blood that he shed his
personal blood but the blood of animals
that he offered that he offered correct
and so this passage is not difficult to
understand when you're careful in
studying itm M what is it saying it's
saying very simply that Jesus had to be
perfected
qualified uh by his life and his death
in order to set the record straight of
those who in the Old Testament could not
be saved by the blood of bulls and goats
and in this way they are legally saved
by what Christ did and so you know you
can understand my frustration in trying
to explain this uh
in a synthetic way uh because you have
to study the tenses you have to study
the syntax you have to study the context
who the just persons are trouble is many
people are just careless in the way that
they study uh this passage let me just
read here the way that this is
interpreted by uh someone who who wrote
on this passage if I can find it um
Robert Mory uh wrote um what he believed
this passage means
let's see if I can find it
here uh I might not be able to find it
among all these pages but basically he
says that the spirits of just men made
perfect are are the
disincarnate uh spirit or or the soul of
the person in heaven wow um let me
contrad rival in many many ways yeah oh
here's the here's the quotation okay uh
this is from um from death and the
afterlife page 213 Bert Mor in his book
uh this is what he wrote in this
glorious picture described by the author
speaking about the passage in Hebrews
the Earthly Saints join in the worship
which resounds from the myriads of
angels and disembodied spirits of fellow
Saints who have departed from this life
wow he didn't study it carefully these
saints were justified through faith
while on
Earth and now perfected and complete Ed
in
heaven that the author is describing the
Blessed condition of departed Saints who
now worship God Before the Throne is so
clear that we must agree with the
commentators that it cannot be
questioned or doubted well I question
and I doubt it absolutely based on a
study of the passage continues saying
the conditionalist that's Adventists who
believe in conditional immortality the
conditionalist have never adequately
dealt with the grammar and syntax of
this passage excuse me we
have and he continues saying because the
spirits of Justified men now perfected
who are worshiping at God's Throne are
obviously conscious Souls of Believers
during the intermediate State H totally
wrong absolutely as you study the
passage carefully uh so you know I took
basically the whole Pro the whole
program to answer this question but I
felt that it was very important for us
to uh underline that we need to be
careful of the the way we study the
Bible Pastor B I mean it is very very
important as you will have said that we
study this the scriptures correctly and
we allow the verses to exp to explain
itself if we have to look into the
context and understand what it really
means you know one text cannot
contradict the evidences in the
scriptures as about the state of death
and like I like you said said and like
that gentleman has mentioned or even G
written in his book written his book the
idea that they take this literally to
represent souls or spirits of
individuals to in heaven it's one of
those deceptions that have you know
truly embraced in the Christian world
the idea that you know the soul is
Immortal that somehow when we die we go
to heaven and many people today are
deceived by this you know idea and this
verse without truly being explained as
you have well explained can sort of give
them some sort of you know F you know
Foundation to to declare so but
unfortunately and you really well said
well said the fact that the the way that
some of the words have been expressed or
some of the verses the verbs have been
put into the into this synx have created
this kind of or or open this this window
of a confusion nevertheless I believe we
have a excellent
material on this and I think that our
viewers should look into this with a lot
more time uh your um manual in regards
to the state of the death is definitely
uh must have for any serious Bible
student and so I hope that they can uh
call in and or or download the app I
mean which gives them for free so it's
an option that they can do you know they
do the same thing with absent from the
body and present with the Lord yes they
say oh yeah Paul Paul wanted to be
absent from the body and present with
the Lord right now no that's when did
Paul expect to be absent from the from
this body that's corruptable body and
present with the Lord 1 Corinthians 15
says that it's at the it's at the
resurrection or at the translation that
he wanted to be absent from the body and
present with the Lord absent from the
corruptible sinful body that we have now
uh but you know they simply take that
verse well it's clear as day Paul wanted
to be absent from his body and present
with the Lord as a soul praising the
Lord in heaven that they're adding to
the text the text does not contain that
absolutely and spiritualism this you
know this Immortal soul that so that's
so common in Christian you know you know
the theology in in mainstream Theology
of Christianity it's it's truly one of
the things that are going to deceive the
world they're going to see spirits
apparent spirits of the death coming you
know to visit them or whatnot and so we
see this as a as a uh influence as a
flood coming into Christian U you know
mentality and Christian theology in many
ways and we have to make sure that we
look at the word of God and we study
correctly the word of God so we don't
are not deceived by the enemy in this
bottom line is that the Bible doctrine
of the state of man and death properly
understood shuts the door to
spiritualism amen there's no way spirit
itu ISM can enter the church as long we
as we have the concept the correct
concept of the state of the Dead
absolutely well folks um I trust that
this explanation has been useful to you
uh we once again want to emphasize that
we Delight in receiving your questions
uh whether they're complicated and
difficult or not uh we do the research
that's why we don't do this program live
because when you send when we do a live
program you know we just have to answer
sometimes off the top of our heads but
we want to do the research and we want
to answer the question so that it's
satisfactory to those who are watching
once again thank you for joining us
we're glad that you uh tuned into our
program and we hope to see you at our
next program of the program I'd like to
know
[Music]